what's your first step in writing a
screenplay um
my first step in writing screenplays is
coming up basically coming up with 100
ideas and picking the best idea
um i have a thing called the hundred
idea theory that doesn't necessarily
doesn't have to be 100 ideas but if i
come up with one idea
that's one idea and it could be a
terrible idea if i come up with a
hundred ideas or
60 ideas or whatever i can comb through
and find the very best idea
and then i take it to thunderdome
i take that idea and i go if i write the
script to this
everyone's going to say is going to pick
it apart so i want to pick it apart
first i want to find all the flaws with
whatever ideas
the idea is and try to get past those
flaws
and remove them so that the idea is
great
and when you present the script to
someone else
and they find what they perceive to be a
flaw
how do you react to that how do you
handle it oh that ends up being the
wonderful world of producer
notes and rewrites the thing about
producer notes is that
it's not so much how to improve the
script is how to change it to whatever
the producer thinks the script should be
so the story that i always tell is i
sold a
script an armed robbery strip like heat
to a producer
at mgm the producer's note was what if
they're cowboys
and i said excuse me what do you mean i
turn it into a western he goes no no
modern day los angeles they wear 10
gallon hats
they have guns and spurs and ride horses
and they're cowboys
i said well there's a car chase so
wouldn't the car catch up with the
horses and then it'd be over and he goes
that's the brilliance of it
the horses can ride down alleyways that
the cars can't go down
and so i essentially had to write heat
a script like heat that was the cowboy
version
and it made me laugh because i thought
it would be a great vehicle for the
village people
but that's the producer note and you
basically have to deal with those notes